みなさん、これはドゴン
です。このエピソードでは、ドゴンによる日本の辞書の第7話へようこそ。このビデオでは、日本の辞書研究
を補足するために使用できるさまざまな無料のサードパーティツールを紹介し
ます。
これらのリソースを再び紹介しているため、少し形式的
ではありませんが、多くのことを理解できることを願っています。
このリストの最初の項目
は、実際には
AppleOS用の組み込み辞書です。Alfredというアプリケーションを使用するのが好きです。
これにより、コンピュータ
上の任意のアプリケーションをすぐに起動できる
ので、DI辞書を入力
すると、よく使用するために最初にポップアップするのは、
Enterキーを押すだけで、辞書に
組み込みの辞書が表示されるか、組み込みの辞書が表示
されます。 デフォルトで表示されるの
は、英語から英語への辞書または
New Oxford American Dictionary、
シソーラス、Apple辞書、および
Wikipedia辞書であるため、これは明らか
に学習には適していません。  ng日本語ですが、
[辞書]タブの[設定]ペインに移動すると、実際にはApple OSオペレーティングシステム
に日本語の辞書が組み込まれ
ていることがわかります。そのため、
日本語を母国
語とする人が使用する日本語のネイティブ辞書と
、日本語から英語の辞書
もあります。 これらはどちらも明らかに非常に
便利ですが、日本語から
英語または英語から日本語の
辞書に入ると、好きな単語を入力できる
ので、英語で入力すると、ここにある
ものを学生に言いましょう。
これは日本語でも入力できるので
、計算で入力すると
英語の日の定義になるので
、どちらの方法でも機能します。
これは非常に便利ですが
、基本を超えているため、音声学習には適していません。
ひらがななど
ここに書いてあるものは、実際
には単語の高低アクセントのパターンを示していない
ので、多くの人が
あなたが学ぶことができないという印象を受けています 日本語の辞書
を使用するだけの単語のピッチアクセントパターンは、
日本語から英語の
辞書には当てはまりますが、日本語には当てはまりません-
日本語のスティック
Ariesなので、次のペインに進むと、
日本語は非常に似ていることがわかります。
英語では、ここに
熱アガナ、次にカンジ、そしてここに日本語の平
がありますが、ここにアイコンがあり
、真ん中に数字が0の正方形
です。これはどういう意味で、なぜですか
Appelの内蔵辞書
は、実際には
日本語のピッチアクセントパターンがすべて網羅されていると信じているので、これ
はとても便利です。
これ
が私の理由のひとつです。  Appleコンピュータが大好きで使い続けている
ので、これはすべて
日本語なので、日本語を学び始めたばかりの人にとっては少しわかりにくいかもしれませんが、
基本的には休憩です
日本語のすべての高低アクセント
パターンをもう一度書き留めて、私の音声シリーズでは
、これらすべてを英語で分解するので
、
4、1、2、3、4の日本語のアクセントパターンと
それらの違い、および
特性の種類と内容について話しました。 日本語を聞く
ときは英語を話す人として意識する必要があります
が、さまざまな高低アクセントの名前や特徴を知っているだけでは
、個々の単語のパターンが何で
あるかがわからないため、日本語の辞書を使用する必要があり
ます。 これらを上
に戻しましょう。戻ってクリックします。
もう一度この
ゼロをクリックすると、ここにゼロがあるので、ゼロをクリックすると
、このテーブル内に
0 1 2 3 4 56gakuという数字が表示されます。
ゼロがあったと言うと
、これはこの列にあることを意味します。これは、
ちょっとボンのパターンです。ゼロ
は、単語にダウンステップがないことを意味します。これは、この数字が、単語の
どこでダウンステップが発生するかを示しているためです。
これについてもっと知りたい場合
は、パトレオンシリーズで行った音声ビデオをもう一度調べて
ください。
ただし
、パターンがゼロの単語は、ちょっとボンであり、
1つは
、ツリーの自動パターンキー、キー、
デング、ブームカッコウ、またはオンとオンを
繰り返します。次に、2、3、4、5、6の単語が、ナカ
または オアハカの家族のパターンですが、
どちらか一方になる場合
、コダカとユッカの唯一の違いは、どの家族に属しているかをどのように知るかです。古い
エコーワードの場合、この
数はモレの数に対応し
ます。 単語には任意の単語のコマンドスペースがあり、コマンド1、2、3、4、1、2、3、4
を使用
して、Appleコンピューターの辞書間を循環
できます。コンピューターにいる限り、数秒以内
に高低アクセントパターンを検索できます。 日本語の単語
なら Appleコンピュータを持っている人なら誰でもこの機能を無料で使用するように勧めてください。
私が知っている唯一のことは、
これらの数字は一般的ではないものの
、この辞書に書かれている高低アクセントが何とは少し
違うと思うことです。 他の辞書
はそう言うかもしれませんが、これはおそらく21分の1と
50分の31ですが、非常にまれです
が、以前に発生したことがあるので
、これから紹介する他のリソースとダブルクロスまたはダブルチェックするの
が好きです。
私が発音と呼ぶブックマークを持ってい
て、Enterをクリックするだけで、明らかに
これへのリンクを
下の説明ボックスに入れます
が、ここで設定した設定を使用したこのツールで
は、入力するだけです
。 任意の単語を下に移動して、
このボタンをクリックします。ここ
で分析します。ロードされるまでに数秒かかります。
次に下に移動すると
、単語の高低アクセントパターンを確認できます。
これは素晴らしいです
。fに移動することもできます。 さらに、[生成]をクリック
すると、これが聞こえるかどうかわかりません。
音量を上げてみますが、[再生]をクリック
すると、おそらく聞こえると思いますが、種類があります。
このロボットの声
は、通常、かなり正確な
説明
を提供しますが、
このリソースを使用して単語だけで
なく文全体を実行できることを説明する前に、これは一種の危険なリソースです。 のぼる
おっと、一言ではなく、このフレーズの
高低アクセント全体が見える
ので、この再生を調べると、
これは非常に
便利ですが、このツールは
Google Translateによく似ています。
つまり、 個々の単語に非常に適して
いて、通常は個々の単語を正しく取得する
ので、Appleコンピュータを持っていない場合、
これは日本語の個々の高低アクセントパターンを調べるための優れた情報源です
が、特に複合語では物事が
より複雑になるため
、  d動詞の活用と
形容詞の活用は、
Google Translateがより
長く、より複雑な
ステートメントでより多くの間違いを犯すのと同じように、ますます多く
の間違いを犯し始め
ます。 素晴らしいリソースです。
世界中のすべての単語が
発音されているのを見ることができるので、ここにアクセスして
日本語の先生を直接入力でき
ます。Enterキーを押すと、ここにさまざまなリンク
があります。
ひらがな、それから
吉岡のように見えましたこれ
が何なのかわかりませんが、
ここにあるのはこの日本語なので、日本語のタブにいる
ので、ここで単語自体をクリックする
と、次のようになります。 これらの
ネイティブスピーカーが実際にこの
単語を言っている場所の地図これはコンピューターで生成されたものではありませんこれ
は実際のネイティブスピーカーが言っている
単語です
彼女が東京を拠点にしているように
、通常はここで最高です。なぜなら
、彼女
は標準的な日本語を話すようにいつも私に聞こえるので
、この再生
ボタンをクリックするだけです。時々、2回クリックする必要があります。
単語が聞こえます。 日本語のほとんどすべての単語を聞くことができます。
これ
はコンピューターで生成されたスピーチではありません。これ
は実際のネイティブスピーカー
が私たちのために単語を発音または言っているので
、高低アクセントパターンは得られ
ませんが、  Macでできることは
、辞書をもう一度開い
て、単語がnaquadah
パターンであり、moraと3の場合は再びなり、mora3の場合
はこれが
ピッチアクセントパターンであることがわかっていることです。
パーティクルも含めると単語は同じように見え
ますが、これだけを見ると
少し難しいので
、これを見てからこの
リソースに戻って再生します。この
オーディオとこれを使用します。
ここにあるテキストではなく波形 これは任意ですが、これは
3番目の粒子とモーラのダウンステップを持つ任意の単語である可能性がありますが、
これらのリソース
を組み合わせて使用して、日本語の音声
能力を開
発します
。 同時に、
それは通常私が見つけたものです。
これは、
グラフを見
て同時に音声を聞くことができるという相乗効果だと思い
ます。Appleコンピュータをお持ちでない場合は、このWebサイトを使用して発音Webサイトを使用してください。
ここでもピッチアクセントパターンがあり
、Avaからここにもパーティクルを入れる
ことができます。これは正しいピッチアクセント
パターンなので、これらは無料のリソース
です。これが冗長すぎないことを願っています。これ
は数少ないスクリプト化されていないビデオの1つでした。
1月にyoutubeを始めてからやってきたので、私が犯した小さな間違いはすべて許してください。でも、
外に出てこれらのリソースを使用して
ください。これら
はすぐに利用できる素晴らしい日本のリソースです。
bleで、教室ではほとんど使用されない
ので、
日本語を上手に話し
たい場合は、これらのリソースをできるだけネイティブスピーチに近づけたい
と思います。日本語の音声学に興味がある場合は
、私のパトレオンシリーズをチェックすることをお勧めします。
Dogonによる日本語音声学このシリーズを使用
して、複雑な日本語の
アクセント用語を分解し、英語を理解しやすい
ので、それを超えることはありません
が、そのプラットフォームでのサポート
はチャネルに本当に役立ち
ます。もう一度興味がある場合は、チェックしてください。 日本語の勉強
を聞いてくれてありがとう
[音楽]
あなた